hey so unsurprisingly this video is
probably going to be covering a lot of
not advertiser friendly things
so if you want to check out the full
uncensored version head over to our
patreon we don't know what we're going
to be talking about yet uh but i'm
pretty sure it's going to be pretty
spicy concerning the uh the guests that
we have today it's probably going to be
spicy so if you'd like to check out the
unsensitive version patreon.com links in
the description anyway let's start
hello you cultured gentlemen ladies i
don't care what gender you are you're
all cultured welcome to the trash table
every gender every gender we're from
every journey as long as you're cultured
we welcome every that is our gender
there are three genders
i'm joey and i'm with the boys as usual
and we have a special guest introduce
yourself hello my name is uh shindo el
and i
do a manga
what kind of manga what kind of manga
yeah there we go
there we go
is that how you introduce yourself uh to
you know
some fellows of the public who might not
be so familiar with your work i used to
i just used to say ero mangaka and then
people started saying you don't have to
say the arrow part
manga called smile that's fine
what do you say when they ask oh what
kind of series do you draw oh i i
haven't heard of you uh
oh then i go yeah
okay okay
they normally just stop there they're
like i kind of get it i'm not going to
push too much on this some people do
some people yeah
yeah yeah it's like the same it's like
you know like porn directors who are
just like i'm a porn director you could
have just said i mean
yeah you could have just sent you in
movies that's fine
yeah i think uh it's fair to say i know
the least
about you and your work i think these
two know the most yeah but i'm sure
there are many viewers who also are in
the same position as me where they saw
your name in the title and they're like
i don't really know what it is that you
do so is there some series that maybe
the viewers might know and if not i
guess you'll they'll get an insight into
uh the life of an aero mangaker today
well when you when i got invited to uh
talk on trash taste i did some homework
oh and i saw the episode where you guys
read my uh engine yeah yes and i know
kano doesn't
think too highly of it
this man got caught in 4k
i didn't know we'd be reviewing stuff
that the authors and makers would come
in
[Laughter]
i have no words okay i guess we'll jump
right into it okay you created
metamorphosis right very very popular in
the communities
definitely the most infamous united
states one of the most infamous dogen of
all time i would say especially in the
western community
i've said something about it that i do
actually i do regret saying really now
you're wonderful
so too faced
my opinions on it haven't changed
there's one thing that i think i did
just get massively wrong
i i in the episode i think i said
something along the lines of like um it
seemed unrealistic that the mum would
blame the daughter for the dad oh yeah
right
i think and then i found out it's
totally not unrealistic and that it's
happened a bunch and that i lost a lot
of faith in humanity when i thought yeah
yeah i thought i [ __ ]
who would have thought i feel like this
is just my child innocent afraid i'm
like no a mother would never blame them
yeah so okay
so so i guess we should
this is this is like a trash taste first
never before has a guest come on and
said heard you were talking [ __ ]
get the bell out
she will just smack the [ __ ] out of me
i guess there's a lot of things
so yeah should we explain i guess what
we're going to demonetize immediately
now uh what metamorphosis is
kind of very lightly and we'll talk in
depth more a little later
so like so how would you yeah if someone
asks you like oh you know i've heard
this metamorphosis thing henshin thing
like but i've never read it could you
like sell it to me like what what is it
about
god it's like
that cream for dream but like manga
that's probably that's probably the best
way to explain it that is honestly how i
would explain it as well yeah i believe
i said something very similar on like
the podcast episode where we described
it where i was like yeah it kind of
reminds me of red queen for a dream
where
it's just really depressing but also
there's a lot of sex in it yeah it's
like right
it's wrinkly for a dream but it was only
that scene
that's probably the best way to explain
it honestly i literally the last time i
read it was that episodes i'm trying to
remember what happens it's like a high
school girl meets a guy on the street
and then they hook up and have sex in a
yeah and like in a karaoke
yeah yeah i feel like why am i trying to
explain
and it just keeps escalating and
escalating yeah yeah yeah so like
very adult by the way okay i guess i
guess we're jumping right into it yeah
okay like how did you come up with that
i just got i just got asked what what
like what were your inspirations in
writing that it's a trope right like the
first of all it's the makeover trope
yeah the girl takes off the glasses and
she's hot right yeah yeah
and then there's the uh the garuka like
turning into a yeah
yeah
and that's like i've never done that
before so i'm like let's try it out
and it worked out pretty well that's how
it turned out yeah
damn did you know how like the story was
going to develop before you started
working on it or was it just something
because it's it's like pretty it's a
pretty long story in terms of like a lot
of
a lot of aero manga compared to you know
some one shorts or you know one or two
chapters but this one was typical volume
yeah as a full volume like did you have
everything planned out from the get-go
or did it kind of develop
everything planned out but i
think i said in the afterward that i had
the ending out
before i started right
i think i just
and i was talking to my editors about it
and they asked you know so how does it
end i'm like well i just want her to die
at the end and they're like oh
yeah i feel i feel like her
unfortunately dying was like one of the
high points because
like her suffering had ended by that
yeah
right and that's like did you did you
always know you wanted it to be that
depressing or like i mean like i wanted
i wanted it to be more depressing but my
editor was like you want to speak you
have to put like a little bit of levity
in it i'm like
wait hold on what what what did you have
to cut that would have made it more
depressing like
well i couldn't put as many like drug
scenes as i wanted to right right
because like in the magazine because it
gets published in an uh monthly magazine
right right right
and in the magazine they had to cover up
all the uh drug bits oh so like a
syringe had to be like had a like a blue
on it oh okay
i had the whole like you know like
cooking up the
cooking up the drugs yeah yeah and
they're like you can't do that
oh damn because like the cops are
already kind of
tough on manga yeah yeah yeah yeah and
they don't want like
you know more pressure right
all right because it's it was certainly
rare to see
like drug use in just like even error
mango like manga in general and it was
such a heavy theme which i think is like
super super rare to see you know in in
any kind of media that comes out from
japan right i think insane and manga you
see some drug use
or something yeah
but in hentai it's mostly like
i don't know what it is it's right now
it's like uh it's like aphrodisiac
aphrodisiac
um hypnosis apps and stuff yeah
do you have a smartphone yeah
again i didn't know anything uh about
you the the only work i'd read was it
was metamorphosis and i i guess i didn't
know when they were like oh shinuel's
coming on i'm like oh does shouldn't
well speak english
i didn't even know right i didn't know
anything dude i guess when you made
metamorphosis do you find that your
experience is from like uh because you
were raised in the u.s right yeah does
that have a lot of effect on how you
write manga or is it still very like
japanese i don't know i think
because i i've been told that it's not
japanese it's right like my storytelling
but like
i tried to make it japanese yeah yeah
and um i don't know if my
experiences in new york really helped me
yeah
like i'm sure you've seen a lot of
[ __ ] up stuff
i've seen a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] but
like
you know i try not to like
directly put that into my storytelling
yeah yeah it would kind of be like
alien to most japanese readers i'm just
projecting all the florida man stuff
i've seen
a florida thing right that's got to be
in one of them i mean i'm sure that's
also the case considering that i think
like for a lot of japanese people new
york is kind of like seen in this like
glory light type of like you know like
new york wow you know like
like gritsy new york or like 80s new
york where it's like yeah like you know
everyone gives a [ __ ] yeah yeah exactly
oh my god just metamorphosis man
did you expect it to be as like big i
didn't expect it to be like so memey
yeah yeah i i knew of the image of her
whereas the glasses yeah yeah as an
anime fan there's some images that are
like almost iconic yeah yeah and one of
them is the girl with the glasses yeah
yeah oh if you know you know yeah yeah
yeah
yeah oh my god yeah did you like when
you released it was it something that
immediately got like picked up by the
community or was it something that you
know you released and you know you had
the usual reaction and then over time it
just blew up in popularity and it was an
overtime thing because like when it was
in the magazines it was because the
editors didn't want to put it up front
because it's kind of like shady yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it was always at the
back
damn
trying to push it under the rock yeah
it was kind of low-key for a while until
like like people um i think online just
picked it up
yeah and started memeing on it yeah
because i remember when i when i
interviewed you like three or four years
ago uh i asked like if you know like the
memes and you were like oh yeah i'm very
upset
because it's just like i don't know like
do you write do you think like the memes
like kind of
i don't know take away from like the
the message that you were like trying to
portray in metamorphosis or do you think
just like kind of just like no i enjoy
the memes it's whatever that means is
fine i don't really
like i don't think about
putting out a message when i make a
story right right you know just like you
want to talk about all that yeah i mean
like
i just wanted to make it entertaining
first and foremost yeah
but i think a lot of i felt entertained
or something yeah well you know
yeah
but i think i think though like you know
regardless i think like a lot of people
read metamorphosis and was like
there's some there's some hidden message
here there's like some kind of like
deeper meaning like to this like story
because it's just so different to the
standard dozens you would read right
like yeah you know the normal dosing is
just like boy meets girl boy fox girl
yeah that's kind of it you know i mean i
would say like out of every you know um
error edition i've seen or era manga
like i was probably like the most
invested in any like story as i was in i
wasn't as invested in any other story as
it was in metamorphosis in terms of just
seeing the characters develop in
in the development that you gave them
and just you know
every like a lot of things outside of
just
the hentai scenes and the sex scenes and
everything
i was probably invested in in the
characters and the ending and that also
also made me even more invested in the
aero scenes as well i thought that was
like fantastic you know i don't know how
much of it was planned on your ends but
it was it was absolutely incredible well
as long as there's like a seal of a
story in there i think people pick up on
it yeah yeah yeah yeah cause like you
know a lot of hentai i think especially
since maybe
early 2000s
they've been streamlining it to make it
more like like i don't know fappable
yeah you know like like they just jump
straight into the [ __ ] and i'm just
like come on come on guys like there are
some dozens i've read where i'm like i
feel like i've skipped like five pages
yeah yeah because this is no build up
yeah when i when i open a dozen it's
like page two or like even
page one come on guys yeah page one and
they're already [ __ ] like whoa whoa
chill out
goddamn like i'll take that over the
hentai that start with like three
minutes of text explaining that
who thought that was a good idea no like
some people are super into that right
it's like
yeah they are like what this it's just
like it's like star wars text on this
yeah some movies just start out with
commanders yeah yeah it's happening
it's the same people who enjoy you know
the interview sections at the start of
porn right like
they want to like get into the story
beforehand it's like i want to feel
invested in this yeah i i have noticed
another trend that's i've seen a lot of
um error manga recently or just not even
recently it's just like it's like you
know like where they say the most
important part of a youtube uh video is
the first 14 seconds yeah so like
there's some error manga that start off
with just like the [ __ ] for like the
first three pages and then it goes to
the story like you gotta hook the
viewers yeah it's like it's always like
page one they're [ __ ] and then it's
like this is how it happened
there's like an omega algorithm yeah
i'm
very interested to know how to so you
lived in new york right right how do you
then go from living in new york to being
like i'm going to start drawing arrow
manga in japan like how does that how is
that the transition that happens well
i've always been drawing right right so
like
and you know when you're a kid you want
like i want to go up and i just want to
draw right yeah
and after college i'm like okay how do i
do that
right right i'm like i could i could
start in the u.s but then you know
there's the comics industry and it's
kind of like it's it's
kind of uh
what i'm like but it's it's never you
know what i'm saying yeah
you have to do this sort of work yeah
right and if you want to like vent off
it's like really minor it's like super
underground yeah yeah yeah like you know
just like a very porn section but it's
like
that's how you make money right
exactly you want to be friends they're
loaded dude sprouts deviantal
japan is like this huge and like back
then like
uh mid 2000s
there was hardly any download like manga
yeah
there's like dl site maybe and that's
about it
so i'm like
it's like that's a little boy to
just upload stuff and like you know
solid like [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah it's great i mean i guess it
was like the closest to having like an
independent scene where you could just
easily upload and just you know kind of
get your work out there instead of like
having to go through like so many
publishers and getting picked up and
stuff like that
and i guess like a good way to like grow
organically as well right because like
those kinds of works are just spread by
word of mouth yeah so you're always able
to speak japanese is it oh i had to work
on it i'm not okay okay i spoke it yeah
but i couldn't like really write too
well
you know and if you ever saw those like
i don't know if you read like a bad
translation you know i'm talking about
yeah yeah you know it's like bad
translation
i have to so i you know spent a lot of
time like just playing uh video games
and like reading novels and stuff
research just research
you helped me out you know yeah so you
were doing it
have you always been self-published or
did you come to japan self-published
teams in japan self-published and then
like a publisher like picked up on it
mm-hmm okay it's like hey you want to go
on a magazine sure why not yeah
awesome so like
why did you choose to be like on the
aero side of things then well i've
always been interested in the ill side
like how did you get into the era yeah
yeah yeah cause i feel like every like
error manga artist always like kind of
the the beginnings are always different
oh yeah right
well my beginnings were like i think my
first
um
dojin was a
planet of the apes
[Music]
dr zaius
i want to read that now oh my god
wait wait is that like how did that idea
come about you were just like watching
planet of the ace one day and you're
like i want to see i can make this
harder
i remember seeing a porno
that was like a plan with the apes
like back when i was like uh like a
teenager right i'm like it just stuck in
my head
yeah bad
i was like what the [ __ ] was that and
like it's still it was like just eating
away at me and it's like i have to draw
this and like i just put that out oh my
god planet of the gates
that's probably what it was called
an accuracy did it do well did people
like i did not do well
i mean i'm surprised there's an audience
if you ask me handful i think would buy
one of these 70 more people than i
thought it was gonna be
jesus christ i printed like a thousand
copies
like jesus i was gonna like print a
hundred
but then it's like if you're gonna print
a hundred it only costs like so much
more to print a thousand yeah
so what happened to these copies where
are they um
i started like they stuck with me for a
while like every time i go to a comic
con i just like put a little bit out
oh okay okay so after like you know 10
12 years like i finally got rid of all
my
background
that sounds incredible it's like it's
like a bonus item man again now so how
old were you when you drew this planet
of the apes oh my god like 20 something
no
no
she's such a bizarre
that's the most bizarre origin story
i've ever heard
the planet
that sounds like a meme
tell me how you got it
tell me how you got into hentai well
planet of the year so there's this movie
called planet of the apes right
so after planet of the april what came
next yeah i mean after that it's pretty
standard um
there's a dragon quest
yep okay oh yeah yeah i've seen that one
it's favorite very popular yeah
and that's when my uh my first editor
came to me and like hey this is pretty
nice right
yeah like i gotta ask like as um as an
error artist how do you choose which you
know aside from your original work how
do you decide to choose which works to
draw
porn about i guess like
did you do you go with like the
algorithm to be like okay there's like a
bunch of this is like this is hot right
now hot commodity right now or do you
just go with whatever you're a fan of i
think
my uh
primary motivation
is like
drawing stuff that i want to read yeah
yeah
isn't available
oh no okay okay like if someone drew it
i wouldn't draw at all yeah yeah yeah
it's literally the [ __ ] i'll do it
myself
that's awesome you found like the 70
people that wanted a plan yeah yeah yeah
and yeah with the dragon quest like you
know there wasn't anything that i found
like satisfying enough yeah yeah i'm
like do it myself
like how do you
how i guess how do you develop the
skills to draw h manga and error manga
specifically because did you have to do
a lot of practice or a lot of research a
lot of research
research wink like did you go to like
art school and stuff like that i did uh
major in art in um college okay right so
does that but it doesn't really help
right right i mean like i you know you
learn anatomy and like how to how to
paint how of like i mean i'd argue
anatomy is quite important in aero manga
but you know
you don't really need it
yeah but i'm like you know you know what
i'm saying is like you don't really see
arrow manga in the style of like bucky
yeah you know it's like
it's usually like usually more more so
than anything you know like you read the
kama sutra and you're like okay i think
i kind of figured out like basic anatomy
and like basic like you know uh
positions and stuff like that the beagle
is more important than anatomy
damn that's wise lawyers are there put
that i want to put that put that on a
t-shirt put that on
because you know you see some artists
and you know
hips don't go that wide or like you know
boobs don't go that big that's true
that's true but it doesn't matter
because you know that's what he's into
yeah yeah yeah like how how much do you
like to stay i guess
true to
what am i trying to say here like a
human physique are you true to the human
physique oh like i have my own
preferences but like i try to you know
expand them whenever i can yeah i'd say
your style is definitely more rooted in
reality than a lot of artists i've seen
yeah
yeah i mean you know there's a
it's a wide variety yeah like there is a
very wide range about how
artists see the human anatomy especially
in dogen
oh my god
like some artists i'm just like have you
ever seen a human in your life
like that is not that is not what humans
look like
that's what they want that's what they
want though
that's what they want man that's what
they want oh my god yeah i think the you
know obviously that metamorphosis uh you
know is one of your biggest uh series
but like uh you've had like a couple of
other like long form yeah ones as well
right like um tsf i think
yeah tsf one of atari is a big one um
there's also the dragon ball one over
out of yours oh you've had the broly one
yeah
yeah
the personality's there but the fur is
gone
[Laughter]
yeah it's really wholesome it's just
like broly being like oh there's this
thing called sex
and i need some help with it because he
sucks literally a 40 year old virgin
right yeah yeah exactly he's literally
like the 40 year old version of dragon
ball universe
he [ __ ] everyone yeah
because like in the in the dojin he like
discovers what a boner is for the first
time and he's like what is this i don't
know what this is i'm scared
what do i do it hurts what gives him a
boner initially i think it was uh the
chili she remembered
the green skin girl yeah i think
she was masturbating and like
they were like
what is she doing
something's happening
oh my god
he literally had he literally had that
reaction of like when you discover porn
for the first time it's like oh what
what's going on what's going on what the
hell yeah
yeah what is this in my pants yeah oh my
god so excited yeah i got asked how do
you what's your creative process around
coming up with like the different
concepts of you know your different
works and everything like that do you
have one or is it just whatever
sometimes sometimes an idea just comes
and you just start drawing
well sometimes i
you know
see a work of art and i'm like like a
movie or a novel or something that i'm
reading and i'm like
if there are only more sex scenes
[Laughter]
the best thing i've ever heard yeah i
guess that's how like metamorphosis
happened right like you're probably
watching like recording for a dream
something similar you were like this is
way too enjoyable
i need more more of this please
[Laughter]
no one wants to see getting
see your arm getting chopped off and now
his mother you know going insane we want
the ass to ask the ass more else the
hearts
which now that you know that i think
about it is basically just was the
storyline of the main heroine right yeah
holy [ __ ] i'm just like
i've just connected that together how
many pages was metamorphosis again like
250 something i think right it's quite
long right yeah how long would something
like that
take because i mean like it's obviously
reading it it's like i can do this kind
of fast i do like um pretty long
chapters like 40 50 page chapters so
like i mean that was released monthly
right yeah yeah yeah so how many months
was that like a year maybe like six
months of uh storyline damn wow which is
crazy and like i don't i didn't do every
month i did like one every other month
oh yeah right right because each each uh
chapter takes maybe like a few hundred
hours of work geez right damn hello lads
it's your boy joey here to let you know
that this episode is sponsored by honey
call me a millennial call me a zoomer
but i like shopping online and one of
the benefits of shopping online is that
you can input all sorts of promo codes
but every time i shop online that promo
code feel just taunts me if only i could
fill it up with some coupon codes to
save me some money thankfully though
honey is here to save the day thanks to
honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past honey is
the free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best ones it finds to your card okay the
boys aren't here to back me up so so you
be the boys this time all right just
imagine you're shopping online and when
you check out the honey button appears
and all you have to do is click apply
coupons wait a few seconds there's honey
searches for coupons you can find for
that site and boom if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop did you feel that symbiotic energy
yeah that's the honey effect you see
this microphone and microphone stand
right here yeah i managed to get 50 off
this massive purchase thanks to honey
and let me just say if you don't already
have honey you could be just straight up
missing out on savings and by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting the show at the same time so
get honey for free at jointhoney.com
trashtaste that's joinhoney.com trash
taste links in the description below
thank you honey for sponsoring this
episode onto the show so like what
what's what's like a day in the life of
you know an error
it depends how much work you have right
you're doing a like a civilized manga
then you wake up you draw you go to
sleep right
and you do that for like maybe like a
month
oh wow do you have like assistance and
stuff like that um when i did um
metamorphosis i had two assistants oh
like most of the tone work right right
right yeah is your office at your home
or do you have like a dedicated office
where are you going i would draw it was
at my home so my living room was like
like desks like
yeah and you had to make room for two
other assistants on top of that oh wow
they're just like on the floor
it's like just cutting tones out
that's just like my image of like you
know these kinds of like small like
manga studios and stuff like that like
the assistants are on the floor you've
seen them before yeah yeah you know
exactly exactly how often do you like
get to work on serialized work because i
imagine you just said it takes a lot of
work so like whenever i want to whenever
you want to yeah you know after my first
um
like volume a volume yeah
[Music]
yeah first uh
book whatever book yeah yeah after my
first book came out you know and it
sells pretty well then people start
giving you like asking you to do work so
and after you you know
gain a little bit of notion then you
know you don't really
have any trouble finding work yeah as
long as you want to work you can oh okay
so that i've been looking in that sense
so you just go on your own schedule
awesome i'm sure you got quite a bit of
notoriety as well like after
metamorphosis all right actually like i
think my first two
like gave me like the most
yeah um yeah
was it name value oh is that including
the plan of the apes no no my first two
like um oh books books oh okay i was
about to say i was like
and uh
you're right right right like my first
two like um published books
i've always been curious because
obviously metamorphosis has been very
like memed up in the western um anime
community
what's like what's the japanese side of
things like how's how's your japanese
audience reacted to your work and
i think
japanese audience finds my work kind of
like
weird
like my stuff is uh a bit different than
like the main
mainstream like yeah yeah it definitely
is yeah in in a good way i i mean yes
it's more story driven i think yeah yeah
definitely so like you know
people and but i just keep trying to put
like a lot of like penta in there too
yeah you know make it work
so i mean like
i think my
in the japanese market my most
best seller is still my first one right
well that's because it's been out long
yeah yeah
so the reaction from the western
japanese audience of metamorphosis was
like really different yeah it's not in
day basically
okay that's interesting how did you how
do you balance like the amount of story
you put in a work versus the amount of
sex scene you put in
yeah um was i supposed to factor
metamorphosis
like genuine question
because i was reading it and i'm like i
don't
when would i
maybe like the first three chapters yes
i felt like
the karaoke scene probably was like the
best optimal point yeah
that one but that one was very confusing
i was like i'm like this is more story
or more
porn i couldn't really was it just like
or do you not see it as that it's just
like it is a story that has porn in it
you can do what you want i think that's
the most optimal way of having a story
with sex in it because like some if you
have a hentai and it's like the story
there's a story part for the first five
pages and then like this next 20 pages
i don't know why i don't know why google
thought we said google but
so like if there's like a story part for
five pages and like 20 pages of sex
then you could skip
the story part can't you
just read the story and read the section
you'll be like
and you're done yeah yeah yeah right
right so is it more that you
you can't
in japan you can't draw stories that
have a lot of sex in them without it
being labeled as like an arrow manga
like are you would you say you're trying
to draw more stories than trying to draw
something to fap too in a way um i think
it's
it's a little bit of both but i think
it's
sexier if there's a
story right sorry i agree with that yeah
okay okay so so like your biggest
challenge is not putting story
in uh in your work but it's
incorporating it in a way that sex
should be an integral part of the story
i think okay thank you thank you
someone someone who gets it thank you
that's why you're the legend
so it's the goat yeah
because like you reach some hentai manga
and you you there is a very like clear
distinction between here's the story
part and here's the second part yeah
metamorphosis didn't feel like a like a
porn thing for me yeah it felt like a
really dark story and very adult yeah um
i think that's why it drew so many
people in though right because like
they're probably going into it expecting
it to be like five pages of story 20
pages 16 and then you're like hold on a
second but yeah i'm just wondering now
because it made me think like oh does
japan have like a if it has x amount of
sex in it would they just automatically
put it in the oh it's porn even if the
story is very fleshed out and very i
think there's no like
there's no like clear-cut line between
like porn and like a story with sex in
it because you see a lot of singing
manga with a decent amount of sex in it
yeah yeah true i think it depends on
like just how much you're showing right
probably i guess so yeah there's like a
lot of like sane in manga and like sex
scenes and stuff like that it's usually
like you know you only see like the top
half or you know like it's like moaning
faces yeah or just like a moaning
yeah it's like oh it's like completely
whited out or whatever whereas like you
know a lot of doujins yeah it's white it
out but it's like very minimally whited
out yeah you know do you have like a
unconscious page count that you need to
reach in terms of like i need to show
sex for this amount of patience because
i do notice that with a lot of manga
where it just feels like okay okay you
have a typical manga it's like 20 odd
pages that's like five pages of story
and dialogue maybe and then 15 pages of
session i think if you have an editor
they try to give you like a set limit
yeah like don't like chill my dick can
only get so hard
so like you know if you're making if
you're making a 30 page manga yeah your
editor would say at least 20 pages
should be sex what wow
so if you're working under those
restrictions
it's hard to make a good story yeah yeah
yeah because you only have 10 pages of
story yeah you have 10 pages of story
that's why if you put like if you um
incorporate the story into the sex then
you have you know all those pages to
work with yeah yeah and i feel like that
just made makes the work
better in general if if you find a way
to incorporate it somehow but like i
guess
like
i guess it's hard because one so few
other
mangakas do it um
and two i i guess you really need to
think about what kind of scenarios
really work in terms of just here is a
scenario that is just not you know a
baseline scenario of just like oh sorry
big brother i got like stuck in like a
washing machine or something you know
what is that how does that work
are there any tropes that you really
hate seeing
oh i mean like
i don't hate anything really yeah it's
really execution yeah okay
so it's not so much the device more yeah
it's used
that makes sense
would are like some of your least
favorite tropes you've seen in hentai
manga than or in in in your field oh
well they may be like a trope you
wouldn't never personally use yeah oh
i don't know like
walking into like a girl bathing
sleeping and then like oh
catching yourself by the boobies
so basically every scene into lover
the entirety of twelve that goes beyond
just like hentai manga that's just like
yeah
in general right yeah
it does get old very fast but it's a
classic though it's a classic but it's
like there are i feel there are
especially some like uh you know h manga
that it's just like
every chance they can get it's like so
we have this new girl character yeah how
do we introduce her to the audience
they better be stinky because they're
going in the bath right now
yeah
how much research you have to do for
when you work on something you just have
to say research because it is a research
man
it's it's the only guy i could talk to
and ask if it's actually research
because it is research yeah like the
more you do the better because like
there
there's so much work out there that
there's always some kind of new way of
showing like a scene like a new angle or
a
a new device of like you know showing uh
whatever yeah yeah yeah that you know
you could always incorporate into your
work so like you know you should always
read other people's stuff um i mean yeah
porn makes like marvel's output look
like nothing yeah there's so much out
there it seems it's insane especially
every time yeah why are there so many
transformer ones
i don't know
transformer which i don't know i have
noticed that actually
every time i've gone to the stores
there's like 15 optimus prime getting
boned people yeah i find transformers
sexy i don't know i mean
bumblebee does pee on something yeah
i guess that's maybe fuel
yeah i've noticed transfo there's a lot
of transformers and sailor moon like
sailor moon makes sense
sailor moon makes more sense yeah but
you find people doing sailor moon these
days though i don't know i still find a
lot of like i don't know if they knew
necessarily the most popular ones now
like ones to make doughnuts well there's
always the you know people who do the
newest thing
yeah uh
fate is always popular
um one that's any of the idols idol idol
master yeah one that's big right now is
like blue archive stuff oh yeah that one
there's a lot of that can you explain to
me
how the dojin like rules or laws work in
japan because okay everyone knows that
japanese copyright laws are like
non-existent they don't
you literally you know there's no fair
use or anything like that but it seems
to be like doujins have been like all
right we'll let you we'll let you slide
like what's there's an honor code
basically okay okay where if the um
original copyright holder says no
doujins you shouldn't do any indulgence
okay i don't say anything it's [ __ ] if
they don't say anything it's fair game
okay oh wow so they kind of just like
turn the blind eye or something or yeah
basically i mean like
um
recently you know there's been um
yeah yeah yeah and they said no doujins
people really don't do it oh wow okay
almost feels like you're a waste not too
though yeah you think that's like the
one series as well yeah like that's like
waifu's galore right for a lot of the
fans so you'd think there'd be like a
massive market well you know it's based
on like real life voices oh yeah you
know it's kind of like you know you
don't want it i guess like weird
politics coming like that right
my baby i don't want to see my baby kind
of like yeah
better stick to apes right yeah
horses overrated
absolute attack that's the real [ __ ]
right there
i can't get over that i really want to
read that
yeah so like how much of your work goes
into preparing for basically comiket
because like like and how much is it
just in general trying to appeal to like
you know just the mass audience and you
know putting your work online nowadays
well
back when you know there was comiket
um
you know twice a year
that's like the main bread and butter of
like your doujin work right
so you know two of these and then
that was pretty much like a few years
ago moderately successful dojin artist
then come here twice a year you could
live off of it right damn okay wow you
know
so people usually do that and then like
other dodging events on the side or
like magazine work on the side yeah
how hard is it to get like a booth or a
table a comic yeah like what's the
process of that comic by the way it's
like japanese comic-con it's massive
comic market very complicated
very huge it's like what like 300 400
000 people or something that's insane
it's the biggest convention right by far
it's i think it's one of the biggest
conventions in the world yeah
and it's all the ocean yeah it's it's
all dogs
it's old ocean yeah it's it's not like
it's not all like hentai it's like every
kind of
okay because dojin just means like you
know self-publishing self-published
stuff yeah yeah so like a lot of like i
learned that from trash takes as well
yeah cause so there's like there's like
entire sections of comic-con where it's
just like the non-errors yeah it's like
just like novels or like
music or whatever
that that can attract that many people
yeah yeah i feel like there's a
convention like that in the us or the uk
i don't think it would be nearly as big
well because like it's anime is just a
lot less accessible over there you know
like you know if they want the same kind
of anime convention experience here in
japan you just go to akihabara yeah
right it's it's a lot so i can
understand why
there is this market for this here um
but
it seems like you know like like you
said a lot of livelihoods depend on
the two main comikets right um so like
how hard is it to get a booth there or
to like to be a part of that event like
if you're
established then you get a cup i think
you get priority seating right now if
you've been to comic-con before and
you've been consistently like putting
stuff out yeah they'll look favorably on
you and give you a space mutually mm-hmm
but if you're new then it's it's like a
nice throw basically sometimes you have
to know someone or no i mean
it really is pretty random oh okay wow
yeah it's gotcha it's got like
it's like ticketed events in japan just
lottery right yeah yeah so it's like
it's completely luck which sucks because
it's like well i was here first can i
have a ticket please yeah you'd think
it's like first come first serve right
but yeah yeah because how did you get
your first booth in comic yet i just
applied you just supplied yeah
and then he rolled
and he wrote the ssr or the ssr
so if you're like not established at all
and you go to communicate right how are
you getting people to come stop by the
booth or check it out
people walk by and you're like hey take
a look at my stuff and then that's how
you have to do it but there's i think
there's also like a lot of comic goers
who are just there to purely consume all
the new [ __ ] yeah and they're kind of
like there to like as like scouts almost
to be like you know how many tables are
we talking how many sellers have no idea
thousands
oh my god yes it feels like if you're if
you haven't made a name for yourself how
on earth would you stand out if there's
thousands of people i mean if you're
seeing like a picture of comiket it's
like you get
it's like a sea of like you know yeah
you get drowned out easily so it's just
like you have to you know hope someone
walks by and you know takes a look at
your stuff it's literally like busking
on the street right it's just like you
just have to hope
that you're drawing enough that you just
have to hope you're drawing enough
attention where someone will stop to
like listen well nowadays you know
there's twitter and other like right now
you can have an online presence before
you do comic-con yeah yeah how important
is that as an aero
artist
old school so like it doesn't matter
yeah yeah yeah cause i i started before
twitter right so yeah i guess you were
already established before the social
media thing right yeah nowadays if
you're studying it's it's definitely
important to have like some kind of
online presence and i feel that like
just you know i think in especially on
twitter like that community as well as
like really supportive of other artists
like i see like dojo and artists i
follow on twitter retweeting other dojin
yeah all the time
i don't retweet any of it mind you i
only like it
it just appears on your timeline that's
all yeah i think i think i follow like
two doujin artists or something yeah um
like at the start and then like just by
following one or two my entire timeline
was filled yeah with hentai because they
they're constantly retweeting each
other's stuff
must know as well when you scroll and
stop for a moment i feel like it knows
because it starts oh yeah keep pushing
it like you want more of this right i
spent more than two seconds on this yeah
you stop scrolling for five seconds
you know here twitter is like a cesspool
but like you don't really see it if
you're doing doujin yeah well that's why
half the people are following twitter
are just dojin artists
because i don't want to see that other
[ __ ] horrid cesspool on twitter yeah
it's like the pornhub comments section
right which is like the most wholesome
comment section you will find on the
internet it's like yes king thank you
for your input appreciate it w plus i
can
everyone's got too much postmark clarity
to look yeah yeah exactly
truly focused truly enlightened
i can't plus i asked
yeah like i guess have you um
have you ever thought about having like
putting more effort into having like a
more like bigger online presence and
maybe like growing your audience there
and getting like an audience that will
you know support a patreon or like
i have a patreon but i'm really bad at
updating it yeah yeah yeah yeah cause
i'm just too i'm i'm lazy first of all
but like when i get into like drawing
something like if i start working on a
project then i'm too focused on it to do
anything else yeah yeah yeah so like
updating a weekly thing is like oh god i
have to spend hours like doing that yeah
yeah yeah yeah what about like stuff
like uh like do you have like a skip or
anything like no not at the moment
obviously
but then it's like more stuff i have to
say oh yeah that's true yeah that's true
do you want to explain what scab is skep
is basically like it's it's like fiverr
where you can like commission artists to
draw whatever it is you want and like i
think in like recent times skep has like
really gotten massive overseas just
because like a lot of like independent v
tubers you know especially like higher
japanese artists because you know it's
like
i'm an anime you know i'm a virtual
anime girl who am i going to get to draw
a virtual enemy girl probably an anime
artist with an anime style right so
that's like really blown up recently and
like i know like a lot of like
independent artists and like dogen
artists like live purely off of skip
commissions right like some some artists
make like bank off skip yeah
yeah i mean and there's a lot of porn
yeah on scab like a lot of porn
there is it's like an insane amount of
pawn on screen it's a lot of porn while
the pawn that could be commissioned by
very very talented artists exactly like
the
the disparity between the work you see
on fiverr and the workers that you're
skipped is like night and day
not even a comparison yeah that's crazy
how good yeah if you want to go
commission good arts uh good artists uh
go on skep and like skep has like a
feature now where like even if you write
the commission in english it auto
translates to japanese oh it does that
yeah yeah so like a lot of japanese
artists now like you don't have to write
in like broken japanese like the the
order translation yeah you don't have to
be like konichiwa commission please you
know like you don't have to be like that
now so like yeah because like i know a
lot of like my english speaking friends
who don't know a word of japanese so
yeah just commission a bunch of japanese
artists and they get exactly what they
want oh cool yeah yeah so it's really
cool they really like optimize that yeah
like in in like the hentai world do you
normally find you find like
that there is like ever certain trends
or like a meta that gets popular between
like different artists oh
i i'm i'm so curious what the world is
like basically oh yeah i mean like
sometimes there's um
i think i can't think of a good example
like uh oh like recently not too
recently a couple of years ago there was
a meta that was going around that was
like a fixed camera and so like for a
few panels it's like for a few pages
it's the same oh
i remember there's like a time lapse
yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] it's like 11 a.m they're in
missionary and then it's like 2 am
they're in doggy
and it was the same angle
they took a water break
[Laughter]
oh my god that is
it reminds me of like that fight scene
in old boy where it's just like one
static together but then you just you
just extrapolate that with sex and
that's just that was just that mess oh
my god that's so weird like i never knew
that there was like notice it now yeah i
know now that you said it i noticed it i
remember it's like there's like montages
in like 80s films where it's like it's
like time-lapsing
except sex
oh my god yeah now that you say that
i've read so many dozens that use that
yeah recently oh my god i never thought
about that that's crazy yeah because
like i don't know like do you know how
how often do you try to like break out
of the trend or like do something
original or do you
sometimes read some works and you're
like damn that's that's awesome i gotta
incorporate in my own work as well
well
when well i don't know if i'm
if i'm weird or not but like it has to
interest me yes i'm not going to have
fun drawing it if i'm not going to have
fun drawing it yeah and i don't do it
yeah yeah of course of course yeah you
got to put your passion into you know
some people you know are really
professional and they just like i i draw
what i'm asked you know but like you
draw what's hot you know yeah right yeah
yeah but i can't really bring myself to
do any of that so like if it doesn't
really like you know
[ __ ] twisting you spock joy yeah yeah
then i can't do it
if i'm not drawing it i don't have a big
smile on my face
then it ain't
it so like i respect that you know if
if i wanted to do like a
straight-up like boy meets girl yeah
kind of story then i have to put my own
twist on it yeah otherwise it's not
interesting to me yeah
what would the what would the shindo
well twist be in an instance like that i
remember
doing one like basically straightforward
story
which is just like one guy and one girl
just said having sex yeah
and like
i think i made to go like a quad like a
quadruple amputee
i mean like
why not right
so like to explain like late she had no
arms nowhere no arms okay
that's like that's like
i feel like that's like as something did
you read a lot of vasanagi during that
time i mean
but
it was a really wholesome story though
yeah
it was like
just looking at connor and carlos is
like discriminate against four amputees
uh yeah
well that's the end of that scene
i shouldn't and i won't
they deserve sex too yeah exactly
just imagining how you draw the panel
was it like we only have x amount of
budget left get rid of the limbs
we don't have enough time to draw the
limbs
it's coming out tomorrow
i think i'm afraid to ask for how'd you
go about researching how to draw the sex
scenes for that well i i knew like a
purple egg so i i talked to that person
for a bit and like
asked them like how do you you know is
it awkward having to ask them those
questions okay how i didn't ask like how
do you have sex
how do you [ __ ]
how do you like you know go about doing
your daily yeah yeah what do you find
hard to do what do you find like how do
you cope with like you know not not
being able to do this or that
yeah so that that that's really
interesting here so you actually have to
like interview your friend right just to
give yourself a frame of reference
to to draw that right if you didn't know
someone and you wanted to kind of ask
them how would you do you have any way
of doing that like if you wanted to meet
someone who is in a certain condition
you know i don't know you'd have to like
go on to school
any paraplegics here
you want to tell me how you [ __ ]
how often do you have to do this kind of
research where you have to like talk to
someone to see what they're experiencing
i mean it's really just it's just for me
basically because yeah yeah i mean i
don't i i figure you could do it without
doing the research or without asking i'm
sure obviously you're not doing that
definitely do not do that yeah
but like you know if
for me it like adds a little bit of like
i could add one thing yeah that speaks
through to someone who's experienced it
maybe yeah it's like oh yeah i know how
that feels yeah and if you had that one
thing then like it makes the story a lot
more interesting yeah because i remember
when we did the interview and i and i
asked you about metamorphosis and like
how i think you said and correct me if
i'm wrong but like you the big reason
why you kind of came up with like
sucky's characters because like you've
heard of like you people like who had
like similar experiences right and like
in high school who like you know got
into drugs right but like
it's not based it's not like based on
who are you right
but i'm sure it's like a lot of it was
like kind of inspired or like you know
kind of taken from that experience right
well like you know like
you know someone who's been through a
lot of [ __ ] and like
and sucky's into like all the [ __ ] right
yeah
yeah it's like oh she has she had like a
comedically bad life right yeah but like
if you take one aspect of it it could
speak true to someone um
like you know yes that part is i
recognize that part as being real right
right so that makes the story more
engaging have you ever had like anyone
come up to you at like events or
whatever and being like you know i
really like related to like sucky's
character i relate it's like this
particular character that spoke through
today i i get that a lot from like
um yeah sucky oh yeah
damn
i feel bad now yeah
right
i am curious because you said that you
had to
sense yourself
for metamorphosis uh because you were
you're drawing it in a magazine i'm i'm
curious now will you ever
release like
a director's cut i guess the snyder card
like 500 pages
because
i i guess even if you couldn't you know
even if you couldn't release it in a
magazine your audience worldwide now is
vast enough to be able to you know sell
that to you because i'd willingly pay
money to see your [ __ ] director of
whatever you had planned originally now
i know i know a lot of people have been
saying like oh shinuel should make like
the happy end right for like
metamorphosis where she doesn't die yeah
[Applause]
i think yeah i think it's me when i was
reading i was like i think the one thing
that i was like oh my god is it it's so
fast right
in one sitting yeah yeah yeah yeah boom
boom boom boom your life's ruined your
life
your life is over yeah
there's no down time yeah yeah there's
literally no break at all and it's just
like you're depressed
and you'll miss a rule and you're never
recovering and it's like oh okay
all right i guess i'm sad now maybe
that's something you can do on your
patreon right maybe i mean like the
thing about working like in a magazine
or just even doing a doujin is that you
have a certain amount of pages and you
have to have some action in there right
right right so like you know you can't
like spend like like 100 pages like you
know showing someone's life right god
forbid
oh my god i'm actually not [ __ ] in
that time
i'll get bored have you ever thought
about just doing just just doing like
you know a non-h manga or non-era manga
i mean
i thought about it but then like
i just come back to what it can be a
hentai
so every story can be improved by sex i
mean like
if you
if you work it the right way
so it's all in the execution tool yes
yes conor yeah yeah
i think you forgot planet of the apes
this is the man that did it when i
watched play with the apes i didn't
think man i want to see caesar just
[ __ ] go at it
so you see that's the challenge right
that's that's that's how you make
excuses yeah how do you do that you know
that's that's the
mental stimulation right
[Laughter]
my god
i admire it i admire this the
determination to be like i want to have
sex in this
i want to try and find every scenario
and turn that into somehow having sex
yeah like after like doing hentai then
like
i don't know i at first i thought like
maybe i'll
use it as a stepping stone to do other
stuff
but the more i got into it the more like
the deeper the world got right like the
hentai world yeah like i realized how
much more i could do
in hentai than
once i realized that it's like you don't
have to like step out of hentai yeah and
do everything you want in hindi what do
you want to do in the entire world oh my
god everything like
a sci-fi epic maybe i could do that
i think that sounds incredible oh man
okay
noelle looks up at the nice guy and he's
like they could be [ __ ] up there
legends with the galactic heroes
[Laughter]
there's not enough [ __ ] in space as
far as i'm concerned
like there's never been like a good zero
g like sex scene so far in hand yeah
oh do you have to like would you
probably have to research that though
right it's like what kind of different
stimuli would a person be able to get
while in zero g's
there are contraptions that people have
developed to extract each other together
right
right but it's never been tested like in
real life in real life oh wow like
people have been thinking about this yet
and i've been like watching them think
about it
it's like yes i agree
this is a great idea
oh my god
is it hard to go
is it like a normal thing that maybe
someone will do error manga and then
just go back to doing manga is that like
common in japan or is it kind of like
there are people who do ero manga
then go on to do like nano manga oh okay
some people come back right like the
author
the author for security was originally
uh uh
manga uh personal thing or dojima or
like uh um
i think that guy clearly wanted to do
porn yeah of course
also oh i didn't know that
oh wow so it's actually more common than
that it's very common do you get to hang
out with many
other aero manga authors yeah i mean
like
like you know years ago like before you
know kovid yeah i used to go out
drinking a lot like i used to go out
drinking with us and say yeah
you know fly on the wall yeah right yeah
yeah yeah and we just talk about like
you know how next shit's going and like
you know like what what do you want to
do next comic what do you want yeah yeah
yeah
that like the workers must be quite
confused over hearing your conversation
what
they're talking about like strapping
each themselves to each other in zero
g's
or how big is the scene right like um i
have no idea like if you
take everybody into account there's like
thousands of people right yeah
but if you uh take one publisher for
example
like sometimes they'll throw a party and
people get together all the authors
would just you know introduce themselves
to each other yeah you know build
rapport
and after that you know sometimes we'll
just hang out
so you know
it's cool yeah yeah
because like i've interacted with us
on twitter before and it's so weird he
is legitimately one of the most
wholesome dudes i've ever interacted
with on twitter and i'm like
the the dichotomy between how wholesome
he acts on twitter versus the [ __ ] he
draws
it's just like nuts right it's done or
do anything with aero stuff generally
quite chill yeah again i mean you must
have some level of clarity yeah yeah
yeah is that listening to yourself
you're like i like this yeah i think i
think i think what makes a lot of them
so cool is just the fact that it's like
they have nothing to hide
it's like i make [ __ ] like this you
either love it or you hate it yeah yeah
if not then i
[Laughter]
yeah i think um and like hentai authors
er manga go really good at like
separating the fantasy and their reality
so like you know you might be into like
lowly but like in in your life of course
you're not yeah right right yeah that's
that's good to hear i mean
it's like yeah thank
much of an industry you know
you mentioned there's thousands of uh
dogen artists
like what percentage of that are able to
do it for like a living
oh like a fraction oh yeah five percent
maybe like ten five percent yeah damn
yeah how do you see people like trying
to stand out now or like
oh my god like people
are so much better now
so much better now than it was like 20
years ago yeah
like this like it keeps going up and
there's a skill inflation that's i can't
keep up with skill inflation skill
inflation
it is insane you see well drawing stuff
on trains here and even then they're
like like 10 years old and they're
drawing anything better than i'll ever
accumulate throughout my life yeah the
the posts i hate the most on twitter is
like when like a devotion artist or like
an artist it's like just a one-hour
sketch and it's like a [ __ ]
masterpiece of the thing i'm like i
hate you i your art is amazing but i
goddamn hate you
but i wish i could say that no it's it's
the thing i say well like the only thing
that shows up my timeline is like when
artists do like oh a quick one-hour
sketch yeah then they go like complete
the sketch or something and it's just
like a tenth of the interactions i'm
like
how does this work
that's like their only post-working
process like pics now because the only
ones that get any interaction if you
want to be a successful artist on
twitter now don't ever finish your work
yeah just only post the sketches
i know a couple of guys who are just
like so much better than me
but they've never gotten like the no no
they deserve
right they can't you know make a living
on like like just drawing and so they
have to work like second jobs to their
jobs
it's really depressing that's really sad
like how
what is the main way artists make a
living or hentai artists make a living
nowadays is is it still comical or has
there been like a big increase in like
say online patreon oh yeah other i mean
like
online
work has just blown up in the past few
years yeah
so i think the mainstay now is just
download like um you know fans are and
the l site yeah
i think it's like maybe like
more than half the market definitely
right right right yeah because i've
definitely seen especially in the last
few years
uh in you know in the western twitter or
western um
industry i guess it's like there's been
a huge explosion of like
patreons and like
especially like even animators like
hentai animators and especially like 3d
artists
people that make overwatch porn are like
the best animators in the world yeah
like pixar yeah i think i wish they
could animate yeah
somehow they all just decided overwatch
will be like i didn't know you could
animate 200 frames a second like that's
that's it's right there it's as smooth
as hell it's like
like they're like
obviously i i've seen like western
side of it but like on the japanese side
it's like a if you are like one of the
top artists is there a potential to make
a lot of money from it or is it still
quite limited on what what you could oh
my i think if you're one of the top like
artists i think
nowadays in the next
past few years of course
i think
having the online presence is a lot more
important than right
so you know people have like you know
half a million like followers on twitter
or something yeah
and you know i think yeah they can
easily make as much money as they want i
think yeah yeah why not right yeah i
have no idea i mean there's probably
there's probably also a lot of like dojo
artists who have like you know found
success
because of their social media presence
by like doing stuff that's not
necessarily like dojin stuff because i
think like i think asaki sensei has like
started like illustrating like a like a
regular manga series or like a line
novel series or whatever it was like it
was like illustrations for novels yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it's like you know
there's like a lot of light novels i
know that like where the illustrations
are done by like doujin artists right
like a lot of people know them from you
know stuff like that right like you know
like pochi for example yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like
was just like so massive for him exactly
but even though for her sorry for her
but uh you know but
even though
she did that she still does dogen [ __ ]
yeah you know she's a youtuber now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
like that that's the next step every
dozen artists is going to be a visual
yeah they always come back
let's come back literally become the
plot of error manga sensei now where
they're just they just live stream their
work exactly
exactly
i i gotta ask because i've been curious
maybe you can explain it right right
what is up with those pesky black lines
everywhere i look everywhere oh i see
all i see is the pesky black now it's
just like a white splat or like the
white splotch or sometimes if there's
keep changing
um
i think it's
well i know it's you know
some
a very uh
complicated dance with
okay okay because um they'll come in to
a publisher especially and say
too much
right right right
so yeah so you guys put as little as
possible to not like anger the people
who make up the rules eh the uh well you
know people
the publishers keep trying to push the
limits but then there's always push back
yeah
and like when um
tokyo olympics were happening
like the build up to that was just more
and more censorship right really yeah
right i mean they got rid of porn
magazines from combines right because of
that they did yeah that was one of the
things that the tokyo government decided
to they were like we're gonna have a lot
of people coming to japan and we don't
want people coming here for the first
time to walk into a [ __ ] family mud
and be like there's a lot of porn mags
here
next to like all the manga that's uh i
don't even looked at them but i thought
they were still there but i think it
must be like lewd stuff then
yeah there's a lot of like graveyard
stuff right but yeah but like the actual
like porn magazines like there was like
you know usually there's like a curtain
you know separating you know those kinds
of like stuff right like in any way but
in combinies it was just there
in the open usually right usually right
next to the toilet yeah you know
it's like it's it's one of those things
where like you go to the toilet and you
take a quick little peek before you go
to the toilet they were like sellotaped
shop
yeah yeah
they're like roped up right
no you all buy it
yeah so they're like that was one of the
things where they were just like we're
just going to eradicate porn max yeah i
didn't realize
you hear from different industries how
kind of like they were on like a blitz
before the olympics to just try and
clean things up yeah sanitize everything
yeah
i mean they like killed airbnb they uh
yeah
and i think they did a few other things
as well i can't remember they did quite
a lot of things they did so many things
they brought a lot of things like
science
just like foreign up
like desanitize
like the whole entire industry um
really didn't really end up happening
yeah yeah yeah yeah but it has happened
in like because everything's more online
now everything has to sort of conform
to uh west tourists
so you can't have like there used to be
a lot more bestiary but we can't have
that anymore
it needs to be a lot more lonely you
can't have that anymore it's be sure
that i can't have that anymore yeah so
like is there any like is it's so
with regards to the censorship is there
any like rules that have been like put
down on paper like let let's say you
know you you have like a penis or a
vagina is there like a rule to like what
part
like like
of what needs to be blocked out like 10
20 or whatever i think like
it depends on like what you're talking
about because like
usually like if someone's putting a book
out in comiket yeah
the people who run comiket will come by
in the morning check your book out make
sure everything's censored to the
standards of whatever the hentai
industry is doing it at the moment right
so now
things have to be pretty like blacked
out right well like you know 10 years
ago it used to be
you have to have a boy like over the tip
you have to have a bar over like the
little flange
[Laughter]
that's the scientific term
and you have to have a ball like
somewhere on the shaft right right like
anywhere on the shelf like somewhere
anywhere on this side i've seen it just
like in the most random places yeah like
that is doing nothing it's like the
middle of the shot and it's like i know
what's behind that
yeah i've always noticed it's always
like the tip and the flange yeah but
then there are some instances where it's
just like
[ __ ] like like just seven lines over
the entire shop
it's like a zebra [ __ ] and it's like
so now it's more like minecraft looking
yeah completely blocked out yeah it's
like it's it's like mosaic but it's not
like fully mosaics it makes sense you'll
still make it out like i've seen like a
trend recently which is like the glowy
dick
it's like you can make like a faint
outline of the car somewhere around
here it's it's so weird whenever you get
that scene whenever like yeah whenever
the girl takes off the trousers and it's
just like a glowing dick
and it's just the most surreal thing i
don't know who started this trend or how
this trend started um
make a scene where like the light source
is coming from that dick
so it works with the censorship
it's like it's no sense yeah my dick
just claws have you ever had to come up
with any creative ways to come around to
get past the censorship well you know
the easiest way is like you know just
work the angles so you don't have to
show as much right right
i feel i feel like also like depending
on like what angles you choose it like
some are even better if you don't like
just completely oh yes absolutely
sometimes it's just like better if you
don't see anything yeah yeah it's it's
paradoxical but like sometimes like you
know
yeah
not seeing the faces sometimes it's like
students seeing the face yeah
yeah actually that's that's that's
interesting like how did you how did you
i guess how do you direct your own sex
scenes you know like how do you know
what looks hot or was it just
kind of like you look at other
references and you're like that looks
kind of good or that there's a tempo to
it like you know you can't have like
money shot money shot money shot because
like you know it just blends all
together yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
need like you know like downtime
downtime money shot you know right right
right although i've read a lot of dozens
where it's just like seven page motor of
money shots
it's like bro like how is this man's
balls not exploded at this point it's
like that's a lot
so
you mentioned obviously uh centering
from the government but is it ever hard
when you're trying to you know dealing
with almost
self-censorship like you have like ah is
this too much i don't know [ __ ]
well you know personally i try to like
push boundaries right right like
whatever makes me feel uncomfortable
like sometimes i try to delve into that
just like you know get a feeling for it
right yeah yeah myself basically
yeah do you feel like that uncomfortable
feeling enhances your story is is that
what you would say it makes it more
interesting
but you're not doing it like purely for
like shock factor it's not shock factor
it's just like
to catch my own interest and like right
it's not for any like deeper meaning
really but like
i mean
i think it makes the work more like
unique unique and spicy it's a little
spicy yeah i'm surprised that you said
that the
white i guess overseas norms affect
the
japanese senses because normally
people are under the impression that
japan doesn't give a [ __ ] what the
outside world thinks i mean the standard
anime industry definitely is the case
right yeah it's strange if the anime
industry doesn't care but then i guess
if to hear the arrow stuff kind of maybe
is more affected by what other countries
think and what i think maybe it's
because like the dojin industry actually
cares for the like international
community even like the normal anime
stuff like um they're remaking they're
remaking
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and like
the foot one of the first scenes is like
a booby shot yeah yeah yeah it's like
what's gonna happen you don't know are
we gonna conform to like you know global
standards or you're just gonna go with
the a's
you know right yeah like complete remake
yeah yeah i guess like
when you
make your work do you have to keep this
keep this into account or was it trying
not to yeah like
i don't know it's it's fantasy right so
like yeah
like
oh this conversation i've had this one
like before more than once right yeah
yeah yeah
like um
do you go about like making something
and like
make it like
because you know it's not socially
acceptable yeah yeah i think
when it's art right it has to be done
tastefully or appropriately right yeah
to be like okay you know you need to
have stories about stuff like this
because it happens you know like i don't
necessarily personally agree with it but
yeah i am okay with it
you don't your characters aren't you
right yeah they're there to represent
something and to push a a storyline and
it's just because you write about a
story i think anyone i i i don't really
agree with people like you can't write
about x topics it's like no i mean if
this stuff happens in real life it it
happens in real life yeah yeah why shy
away from it horrible stuff happens all
the time you should be able to write a
story about it
obviously there are some people who do
it not tastefully at all yeah the
argument i hear a lot is that it
normalizes the uh the act right yeah i i
disagree with that no i disagree i
disagree too but like you know i hear it
a lot yeah yeah yeah hey guys i was
wondering if you have a favorite fruit
uh i like strawberries oranges for me
why are you asking this all of a sudden
well boys because this episode of trash
is sponsored by boxer
boxing
i know a lot of you have already signed
up for boxing which is awesome but for
those of you who aren't familiar boxy is
a monthly subscription snack box service
that delivers premium japanese snacks
and tea pairings straight from japan to
your door each boxu features a new theme
providing a gourmet journey through
japan every single month this month's
theme is manatsu fruits which translates
to in english as mid-summer the couple
of things you can get in this month's
boxu including the mixed berry cake let
me try that joey this is the perfect
combination of light airy and moist mmm
that's good man well the good thing is
gone you can pair that with this satin
sakurajima komikan tea this green tea is
flavored with the peel of komikan the
type of mandarin orange native only to
the kagoshima prefecture
the other one that i recommend is the
maruichinsko pineapple jinsko are a
traditional okinawan shortbread style
cookie with a crumbly crunchy texture
how does it taste
yeah that was so low we receive these
boxes every month and absolutely love
them so if you want to try some rare
japanese snacks with us and support the
channel as well then use our code
trashtaste15 at checkout and the link in
the description below to save 15 off
your first order back to the show so uh
legitimate question okay
dick girls yeah
you know
because you know it's a thing indulgence
a lot there's a lot of it yes and you
have a serious tsf that has dick girls
in it right isn't it yes i've always
been curious
how do dojonatas
get into that
like are you not into it i'm like half
off right into it i'm not like crazy
about it what's the name of the tank
again dick girl was it a dick
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
right because it's like it's when you
think of like you know stereotypical
like dojin tags right like futa is
usually the first one people think of
right because i feel it's a very much
like uh i think there was a there was a
poll that faku did right yeah the most
popular um search tags or post state
first date yeah futo was like all over
the years i think it was like
yeah i think i remember seeing that it
was like out of like out of like the 50
states i think it was like 41 states the
most viewed tag was futa yeah so it's
like it's just i don't know it's just
this really interesting thing that like
i think it's just so synonymous with the
dojian world especially yeah and a lot
of people are so like again it's like
another one of those things like loli
and shutter where it's like a very clear
divide right but and yet it's like
weirdly embraced yes for some reason
right so it's like but like you're not
like personally into it right no
personally i'm not like it doesn't mean
you do anything for me yeah yeah yeah
but i understand like intellectually
how it works like right why it's gonna
describe it intellectually
intellectually
so i try to put it into the work cause
like you know i want to explore
that aspect of so what so what made you
want to explore that side of things well
you know like i've never done it before
i'm like let's give it a try
and like you know the more i try work it
then the more i understand why it works
yeah yeah you know so it's like your
mission i guess is to like go through
every single tag to be like i'm going to
try and explore every single one of
these
that's a good glorious thing
that'd be cool what's like that what's
putting putting your own twists on like
every tag yeah that's a really good goal
is that like a tag you've seen where
you're just like
whoa
what what is that i'll i'll
tell you when i find it
eye penetration i can't i've done it
here's the appeal of that
like it's uh
breaking the laws of physics
like there's penalties in the taboo of
the law of physics like this eye
penetration is ear penetration there's
like belly button penetration and it's
all it all links to like sorry yeah that
made my like stomach like
quiver it's basically all like what you
call leona
which is like uh torture basically right
what a twitch point right yeah yeah
that's that's that's like a really
common tag
yeah there's a lot of any of this is
completely all new to me yeah yeah i
don't read you an innocent child
don't read anything
it is a vast world alberta i'm just
thinking like how would you even
i would how would you do this physically
the orbital socket is like this deep so
you can find like maybe a way to do it i
mean i mean i think the point is you
can't do it physically
that's the appeal of it that's the
appeal yeah it's like i i don't want to
see it in real life i don't want to try
it in real life mrs incredible maybe you
could
i mean
that's one way to do it right well
that's that's not like you you've just
discovered a situation in order to like
achieve that i don't know how much
incredibles porn you think there is out
there
there's a lot yeah yeah yeah yeah
i mean
made of rubber
to make that work realistically
yeah it's like that's like one thing
i've always wanted to ask like a dozen
artists is like when you find those
kinds of like you know
non-vanilla tags and stuff like that
what is it about like those non-vanilla
tags that makes you want to like draw
about it or like you know write about it
or you know like kind of well they try
to get into it if someone
who is really
talented
before and it's like you don't fall in
love with the
act or the tag itself but you fall in
love with the artwork right
so like um i don't know if you know who
godzilla sensei is
i know the name he does like uh manga
um that's about reptiles
okay oh yeah i think i think i'm saying
he does like he does fanboys on his free
time right right and like i've never
been into fanboys right but like just
reading his stuff it's like oh
what's so good like this fanboy is hot
yeah that's that's my exact experience
with asanagi because like a lot of like
his topics in his dojins i'm not
crazy about to be honest like a lot of
it's just like whoa okay but the art is
just so good right yeah yeah they're
like i can't stop reading it it's like
it's i just look at it as like damn he
can [ __ ] draw people and situations
like action scenes like really [ __ ]
well yeah yeah and like i think i just
appreciate him on that aspect and i
think it's like i appreciate a lot of
doji nadas just for that aspect just the
fact that like a lot of them are just
like really [ __ ] talented artists
right right and it's like if i could
draw like that i would absolutely
[ __ ] draw that [ __ ] you know i was
like why wouldn't you it's just cool i
don't know
i i say this because i can't draw good
draw porn is that what you're saying
if i could if i had the talent to draw
porn okay why would you not
i mean especially what they were doing
yes you know and the the churches that's
what they had
right all it's like if i had the talent
to be able to draw like a really hot sex
scene i would absolutely draw my own
sexy yeah because that's just like a
power it's like i don't even have to
look for point anymore i'll just [ __ ]
make it i'll make it i will make the
pawn myself thanos like i'll decline
i'll do it myself yeah exactly
i mean like that's that's why you do it
that's why i do it yeah because it's
like you know you you you look around
and you're like
nothing there that like just clicks for
me yeah so i'll just do exactly what i
want to see and you know what i think is
cool right so it's like yeah if i had
the ability to do that i [ __ ] do that
in a heartbeat absolutely so like what
are some of your favorite tags out of
curiosity um i think
some of my most well-known favorite tags
are like pregnant one right sometimes
birth sometimes like um what is both
birthing birthing like birthing a baby
making a baby
in in the show
the things like well i mean minimal
officers had one right well did it kind
of not merely not really but
[Music]
this one chapter is all just birthing
because i wanted to i'm just giving
birth just giving birth okay
i'm trying to protest
i can hear like the uh
just like
okay i just love i was just looking at
connor when he said okay and just the
eyes darting you like around like okay
i wouldn't ask questions but i'm scared
to know the answer
you might have an opportunity so just
ask just ask so yeah the pregnant thing
i can
all right i can understand that that
could be attractive right yeah but what
about the birth aspect is attractive
well why not go a step further when you
go to if you're into the pregnancy then
why not go a step further
this is water that's the attractive part
well you you know just well
okay okay okay i was making sure i
understand that
you can be like i mean you could like
theoretically do anal while you're doing
it but like you know
doesn't have to i guess you could
that is indeed a fact
the laws of physics
requires
phil i'll fill a pattern which is just
like well you theoretically could do
this
so i think what i'm learning is that
it's it's asking the questions that men
never asked
that's [ __ ] it let's do it yeah yeah
yeah
let's give it a go
i admire the exploration yeah yeah
okay carry on what are the tags what are
those tags um
ishikan which is a cross species
you know usually mixed in with pregnancy
and birthing right right
okay
how many
like sauces like a chef right just like
the ingredients
okay okay and uh well you know the
normal stuff like you know gangbang
whatever you know so yeah it's like
vanilla can you just not do vanilla
anymore
why
go back not the classics right like the
bloney one was vanilla
what was it wasn't it
i wouldn't there's two people and
they're just doing a thing i mean i mean
there's
vanilla like nautical no no
no there is no it's not vanilla because
there was a birth scene
[Laughter]
there was how is birth not vanilla
though
this man's like living on a different
like level of reality he's like i think
i think your version of vanilla and mine
is like so far gone like i'm like
missionary go to bed at 9pm watch a tv
show you know that's vanilla
natural
outcome
no no nothing quote-unquote are natural
right there's a standard human
experience okay that makes sense no but
i get that it's just the fact that
you're like what's not vanilla about
birth it's just like
it's like third eye open it's like oh my
god you're right
this man's like another plane of reality
brain expansion
just like couples getting together
vanilla
it's like an attractive thing to see
just a baby born
i mean like because there's um
the mother has to go through all these
stages right yeah oh and that's the
attractive part of yeah okay okay i
think i understand
i think i feel like you need to like
read some of it to like figure it out
yeah what are the tags i'm interested oh
species okay species um that won't make
sense to me that seems hot yeah well i
mean yeah ish's looking reviewers was
[ __ ] massive right because they're
hot why not yeah exactly exactly i mean
technically like you know the broly one
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly but no normally
normally we're talking about like
non-human right yeah yeah yeah
um what else well you know the normal
stuff like you know
uh transgender yeah
one that i've been doing a lot
um what else have been doing doing well
you know i do you're not too the torture
stuff right right once in a while
um
i recently did a collaboration with
asuna sensei and he did his uh
compilation of like various artists
doing like girls who've been who've had
their limbs cut off right yeah i feel
sorry for the fbi agent
your search
i have to go through all this [ __ ] later
yeah yeah um i haven't done too much
scat
right
except like vomiting vomiting i do a lot
why
i mean like
i'm
genuinely curious genuinely i don't know
it's like
it's i'm not trying to be like
derogatory one of the moments where you
where you feel like
at your lowest
when you're when you're throwing up okay
so so there's kind of an attraction to
seeing people
at a very low point at a very vulnerable
point yeah yeah okay okay i mean yes i
guess on the same level in terms of
vulnerability it's simply like
metamorphosis right very vulnerable just
in different ways yeah yeah yeah exactly
it's the same emotion i guess just in a
different kind of scenario i just love
them
just if you just took that conversation
out of context it's like i do vomiting
quite a bit and you're just going why
that must be so weird out of context you
know
i i i'm
this one episode has been like a gold
mine i'm just getting out of context
clips
you know because i i i like to think
that the podcast is is something where
even if we disagree like i said earlier
it's something where we can come to
understand and kind of talk and share
even if i completely be like that is
[ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah yeah i still
think that you should be able to tell me
about it yeah yeah talk to me and be
like this is what it is and i'll be like
oh god
go ahead king go on i just want you to i
just want you to keep going purely just
to see connor's reaction
this entire podcast just been golden
just like every so often you'll say
something con is just like
what every time you say something that i
know is [ __ ] i immediately look at
connor there's a lot of people who you
know
would kill to be in this chair and talk
to you about this so i don't want to you
know i don't want to squander that
opportunity like no i don't want to know
anything about it i want to learn about
it so i can like live vicariously yeah
yeah yeah and if you don't know anything
maybe you can
do my reaction to this episode
i am living vicariously right now yeah
yeah because i'm just like at least i
know connor's gonna have a more [ __ ]
up like reaction than me right
you know i'm i'm sitting on this side of
the table and i'm like sometimes i feel
like i should be over there
i love i love hentai right hentai is
great you know me and samuel jackson
have a lot in common yeah
you know and i almost feel like hentai
is so goddamn vanilla from what's going
on in the dojinski world
i'm watching it i watch a lot of the
hentai and i feel like what is happening
over there like i feel like
we're in like the villa and you guys are
like fighting down on the street
what's going on down there one thing i
can definitely say after after talking
to you is that i think i have vanilla
taste yeah yeah yeah
i never thought i would say that
i used to say like vanilla that's lame
as [ __ ] but now i think i'm vanilla
your colleagues presumably don't
all draw or cover the same stuff as you
are they ever like bro chill like oh no
daddy chill
no
it's always
what i don't know okay okay i mean it's
always fun to see what other people are
doing right right yeah yeah oh you're
doing that cool you know it's like yeah
yeah i can actually be like yes king
yeah yes you [ __ ] buff that kid
penetrate
here's here's the next dojo episode
we're going to ask you to recommend us
some notions yeah and uh we'll read it
and talk about it actually yeah that'll
be pretty [ __ ]
i'm gonna hate my life
if you're going through my category then
i suggest doing a
shindo l's cultural anthropology okay
because i had the most fun writing that
one okay okay so that's you just
explaining
all the
genres i guess it's like me playing
around with a lot of genres okay okay
just like short stories like sure i know
it's one continuous like it's episodic
oh right oh okay i said amount of set
characters doing like different things
for every chapter okay okay
see a lot of these stuff really
confusing for me because i'm like am i
supposed to jack off i don't know when
maybe you're not supposed to yeah am i
supposed to be like genuinely i don't
know i think i think it's just a matter
of like if you think the time is right
yeah you know how you write it you're
like if you if you want to just read
this and experience it do it or are you
writing it for like all right yeah you
can
do it i mean like
some things i've been thinking about for
a while and like you know okay
i kind of let it like percolate yeah
and then i put it on paper but other
things it's you know on a whim yeah
that makes sense i think yeah because
you know like i don't jack off to every
dojo i read yeah you know sometimes i
just like like reading it because i like
reading it yeah i just watched porn yeah
watch it yeah there's storylines no
but that's the weird thing right i'm not
like that with like porn or hinter
so like what is it i don't know it's
there's there's something about dojins
where it's like it can literally just be
like a pick up and read thing sometimes
yeah i see people on the train today
swiping through dojins yeah yeah yeah
i'm just like
this is a strong world to me
but i just find that really fascinating
that like doujins can do that yeah where
it's like even though you look at the
contents of it and you're like yeah i
can definitely see someone like jacking
off to that that the fact that you can
just sometimes be like
yeah you know what i want to read it but
i don't really want to jack off to it i
just kind of want to read it i want to
read the plan in the april
just curious right yeah exactly i think
it's you know why it's just going to be
so simple i think it's because dungeons
aren't a hands-free experience
right right like like if you choose to
jack off to adoption it is it is effort
because you are you are holding
something yeah
whether it's like you're like juggling a
lot of things yeah exactly like like
hentai you know you can put that on the
tv
now you can put it on the screen you
know back in the day you had to like
find a way to put that hold the book
out
like even if you put on the screen go
like
turn the page
[Applause]
it's not a complete hands-free
experience
i've always been curious like can you
view like porn in the same way or do you
just view it now as completely you know
just research or something that you can
incorporate into your own world oh no i
could still you know
okay okay
yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's all good
that's when you know it's good right
[Laughter]
you're like finally some good [ __ ]
is food more you more prefer to read or
watch
i'd rather read
oh that's interesting for me it's like
the complete yeah
like i'm a manga person rather than an
anime person
right right right right so
it's more about like visualizing it and
kind of like it always works better in
my mind when i'm reading it i guess it's
like i'll do it it's like reading a
novel like watching a movie because you
can like fill in the blanks in your own
way right yeah so it's like you can make
it a lot more like sexy or like more for
your taste than perhaps the author
intended
whereas with like hentai it's like you
get the full package and you can't
really change that you know yeah so i
get it i guess is there anything else
you guys want to ask about hentai
specifically
i think we need like a kind of chill
down section
what up it's your boy joey here to let
you know that this episode of trash
taste is sponsored by
tipsy sake you know i'm traveling right
now and as the resident sake enjoy it i
miss the good sake that japan has to
offer but luckily thanks to tipsy i can
have good japanese sake wherever i am in
the world tipsy for those of you who
don't know is a quarterly subscription
box that curates all sorts of sake
straight from japan because as we all
know japan is full of all sorts of
different suckers and the world of sake
really does run quite deep in fact let
me show you guys what kind of sake you
will be expecting for this quarter we
have the june mai ginjo toyo bijeon
okarakuchi this particular brew gives an
aroma red apple that fades to an almost
nutmeg spice it's a very dry sake said
to be strong enough to kill a devil but
if you want something a little lighter
then why not try the kinone junmai
ginger this sucker is bursting with
enticing aroma and pristine flavor with
hints of freshly sliced apple and a
crisp finish and that's just a couple of
them there are a bunch of other curated
sake for you guys to enjoy different
pairings and taste testings and stuff
like that so if you want to explore the
world of sake and are interested in
checking it out then make sure to go
over to tipsy links in the description
below and not only that for you
trashcase viewers you can use our coupon
code trashtest10 to get 10 off all your
products but wait that's not all in fact
if you use our other coupon code
trashtaste30 you can get 30 off your
first sake bottle that is a steal so
thank you again to tipsy for sponsoring
this episode onto the show yeah so like
you were talking about elder ring
earlier oh and yeah being a massive
souls fan
so uh yeah like what are what are some
games or some anime or something
it's been like a intense two-hour
conversation about porn so far
so i want to chill out
well what are some like games and anime
that you like
or looking forward to or like or just
like in general yeah whatever your other
interests uh
everything
i like rpgs in general yeah like um
strategy games like um
if you played uh valkyrie chronicles oh
yes yes
yes yes just getting into valkyrie
chronicles right now yeah it's a great
series yeah um i mean you're obviously
into like dragon quest and stuff yeah um
yeah this is a new dragon quest 3 remake
coming
oh yeah
yeah i want to play that as well
um what else is coming out oh there's a
was it made in the best action rpg
coming out
is there actually yeah yeah
yeah it's action rpg
and it's it's really that said for like
adults only
oh i want to play that i'm just curious
you know
but i'm always scared of like anime
games because they haven't had the best
probably gonna be like [ __ ] to play but
like yeah you know i'm interested yeah
sure like what can they possibly do do
you like g oh so you like made in the
best thing i do
you know what now now that you see it it
makes so much sense right
because
because i'm just like damn that
definitely explores some topics that i
don't normally get to see right like
he's like made in the business like some
do you know in it right like there's a
lot of torture scenes in there oh god
that definitely makes me feel
uncomfortable yeah definitely
jesus
a lot of sense holy [ __ ] oh yeah what
are like some like standard manga that
you would like recommend all like you
really really like well you know now spy
family's big of course and
i'm more of a manga spy phone guy um um
what else is new
[Music]
so it's just like the most wholesome
thing
that did surprise me
i don't know why there's a part of me
that was like spider family to vanilla
tornadoes expected to be like yeah so
berserk you know oh yes
it's just hilarious to like imagine you
reading spy phone and being like hell
yeah
oh that's so cute
yeah
so so like what's kind of like some of
your favorites of all time then oh my
favorites of all time
like anime of manga or video games
um anything drawn by
about the takahi
yeah yeah yeah
like his recent work with like one punch
man especially it's just yeah [ __ ]
incredible and obviously i shield as
well i don't i don't know how that man
keeps improving yeah it's crazy i
thought he peaked at i shield 21.
and then one punch man was like i could
do better
crazy yeah
that's definitely like another one where
i can definitely see like it kind of
like makes sense because like he also
has like a really like you know darkish
style and like you know especially like
some scenes in death note like
back in the day it was like whoa that's
uh this is it this isn't shown in jump
yeah yeah it's like holy [ __ ] you know
like i definitely remember reading death
note the first time and i just
i i didn't even know it was shonen jump
yeah you know like i knew at that time
what kind of manga was kind of in shonen
jump you know you had like you know you
know dragon balls your
shows you know all that kind of thing
and then you go to death note and you're
like this comes from the same magazine
yeah it looks it looks like a seinen and
it feels like a saiyan in mind yeah so
it's like yeah i remember like walls of
text right yeah yeah
like a novel huh i just can't imagine
reading it and not having like the
[ __ ] elves theme playing
well that's that's that's how people
experience it before the anime yeah yeah
i know but like now i can't think about
death note without having that song in
my head i know yeah it's so iconic yeah
the anime is so good yeah because like i
remember when i first saw that being
adapted because that was one of the few
mangas i read before watching the anime
and i was just like there's no way this
is going to work in anime form there is
like too much dialogue there's people
too stylized yeah just eating potato
chips
[Laughter]
so it like blew my mind that i was just
the anime was just that engrossing where
i just thought there was no way you'd be
able to translate
all of this text going on into an
interesting
into an interesting anime form but they
did it but they did it [ __ ] whoever
directed that was like five head dude
like they clearly knew how to like take
text based and just like very still
visuals and make it visually exciting
yeah yeah you also mentioned you put
many hours into elden ring uh yeah but
almost 200 i think jesus christ
yeah i got like 70 hours in it it's so
good yeah boys haven't played yet for
some reason i don't know why
but it's because i'm trying to find time
to do it because i know i know i've
played enough like like [ __ ] from
software games where i'm like i know i'm
gonna love this game yeah but i also
have commitments
as well yeah and i need to like block
out a week from my schedule at least
there's something is something so
amazing about when that health bar pops
up on the screen
i don't know what it is that gets me so
excited every time like every single
time yeah of course
it's so hard
what a game dude yeah
yeah
what about some video games aside from
eldon ring
i mean i suppose you've been playing
never played uh fps games or anything
like that well yeah i've been i played
apex like when it first came out
i love apex
i think last battlefield where i played
was three though
oh oh battle oh battlefield three i mean
it's been buggy mess ever since yeah
three was kind of he was like like
borderline you know it's like i could
accept this bad company yeah bad company
two was really good
battlefield game god you got okay so
you're a gamer good yeah good he's a
gamer yeah he's a gamer he is a gamer in
the game yeah how much time do you have
to like
pursue like your other hobbies outside
of your work because you hear some
horror stories about manga artists just
like having zero time if you're working
like if you're doing a monthly or weekly
then you have no time
but i guess you do like bi-monthly right
i do buy monthly but now i'm just like
taking long hiatuses let's see like
because i i bought my i bought a house
i'm like fixing it up and guarding
gardening and doing other retiree things
right
but you know i
want to spend more time drawing
spend more time drawing eye penetration
[Laughter]
do you ever get inspiration from you
know works outside you know just from
like normal manga that you like find
elements that you can incorporate into
like your work yeah i mean like if you
look at a
sex scene it's basically an action scene
so if you read like battle manga you can
there's a lot of like angles and like
movements i agree okay i can never tell
what the [ __ ] is going on
and both i'm like
yeah so
when okay
can you expand like like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa i get it i get it
yeah yeah you're you're basically just
um depicting movement right um
so like
how do you get that across like on a
still image right oh okay so you know
you know you do like in and out in and
out yeah yeah yeah that's like one way
to do it and right if you read battle
manga you could like you know we could
incorporate in and out in one picture
[Laughter]
what about like the pacing and tempo of
a battle like does that play into factor
i i've yeah i've never i've never
thought i never thought of
i'm glad you said that because i
actually always thought that like really
yeah yeah i just thought that sex scenes
were just battle scenes
you just think that because bucky said
so
maybe yeah
i'd argue the greatest fight scene in
bucky is the sex scene because the
tension of a fight feels the same as the
tension of a sex scene
that's true in a lot of ways yeah a good
a good the tension in a good fight scene
and the attention of the good sex scene
is like
yeah
it's exactly the same i guess
[Laughter]
yeah like
i guess i guess i'm so curious to to
like hear what like what does that break
down into are you talking about like
just movement or just like the tempo or
the pacing
and movement like
let's say um
you're having a sex scene right right
and you'll notice there's like a large
panel yeah something happening and
there's there'll be a small panel of
like some guy flipping his wrist right
and then the next scene you'll see how
he's using that as his hand yeah in a
different way right and it's the same
thing in the battle manga you know
you're right
one guy's fighting but then he does a
small movement and you'll see a small
panel yeah where they show that and then
that gets incorporated into the next
scene it's a team okay that's so
interesting so
like it's like kind of creating like a
flow right of movement so do you like
when you when you're when you're drawing
this do you have like a kind of like a
rough storyboard in your mind about how
the paneling is going to be
um
like sketching out i sketched it out
beforehand right but you know there are
different you know
you have different templates in your
mind yeah yeah yeah and like
you go by those templates and then once
in a while you want to change it up yeah
make it interesting right right right
right so i'm i think
the more experience you have the more
templates you have in your mind right so
it doesn't become like monotonous okay
that's so yeah because i've never
thought of it like that but now that
you've said it out loud it just it makes
so much sense everyone everyone saw the
moment where it just like clicked and
gone he's like you know like you can see
the light bulb just like oh
god's gonna be watching like demonstrate
getting bricked up
like damn that floor of movement though
oh so you're telling me so you're
telling me if you affordable animate sex
scenes it's just gonna be the greatest
get the greatest greatest
the greatest fight yeah back in the 90s
you had like top animators doing hentai
yeah yeah i know i know not so much
these days but like you know back in the
day it was like we have big names you
know yeah unfortunately we have queen
bee nowadays
[Music]
but yeah like i do know that like hentai
back in the day had some like in terms
of like animation studio and animators
work on it it was like some big big
names
yeah yeah yeah soccer guy
that was the thing that was just fun
i'm a child dude the sakura and 90s
hentai is like insane
it is it's crazy yeah and now it's like
very much you know
the same kind of glossy look the same
kind of template there's less now we're
back to drawing like a frame and then
just moving it on camera like this yeah
yeah yeah i mean it's not all like that
but there's definitely
less
like
experimentation right but now you have
amateurs who are doing amazing like
like um animation work
just on their own yeah yeah yeah like uh
the one in the italian senate yeah
yeah yeah the t
some of foreign some of the most
impressive hence i work so i think we're
going like full circle we have a lot of
talent working in like just doing sex
scenes now yeah yeah yeah
you know hopefully it'll keep going that
way yeah because like i like so like
some of the most talented artists and
talented animators i've seen
um
in the porn world has been independent
and i'm just like damn what if i saw
like because normally you only get to
see like a minute or two of animation
which is of course as much as you're to
be able to see from one person right man
what if he had like an actual 30 minute
episode that like actually looks like
this that would be like insane
you know that man some money yeah yeah
right right give this man a studio right
now
give him a production
that'll be amazing yeah anyway i i don't
have anything more to ask you me neither
man i think i've been i'm i'm full i'm
full i am i'm there was so much good
food i am like enlightened i am
fulfilled right now oh one last question
okay
is hentai art yeah
okay there we go
i thought we knew this
now no one can argue on twitter
confirmed right here yeah what are they
uh where can they find you and also what
should they be looking out for
um
you can find me on twitter
you can see go to thehoots.com i have a
website there
and uh my next project aside from what
work i do for a mobile game
called time running rpg
okay
[Laughter]
i'll also be um i'm still working on a
project for comic unreal which is going
to be a fantasy
epic
wow
hell yeah
yeah well the links all those are in the
description below as always and you said
you had a patreon as well yeah
him on patreon yeah yeah what's what's
the uh
url for that patreon or username i guess
uh schindler i think yeah
yeah so links in the description hey
speaking of patreon look at our patrons
yeah
look at all these cultured individuals
right now
but yeah uh if you would like to support
the show and also uh watch the
uncensored version of this episode
because god knows we're gonna get
yeah monetization mean you know either
way if you like support the show then go
over to patreon patreon.com also follow
us on twitter send us some means on the
subreddit and if you're header face
listen to us on spotify and of course go
check out genocide stuff links in the
description yeah thanks for coming thank
you
the enlightenment was unreal
we are going to leave this office
different men
after this episode
i do feel like all the same way
[Laughter]
thank you so much
thank you for coming thank you guys
incredible episode and thank you guys
for watching yeah see you guys next time
[Music]
you